Large language models are very good
at transforming its input to a
different format,
such as inputting a
piece of text in
one language and transforming
it or translating it
to a different language,
or helping with
spelling and grammar corrections.
So taking as input a piece of text
that may not be
fully grammatical and helping
you to fix that up a bit,
or even transforming formats,
such as inputting
HTML and outputting JSON. So there's
a bunch of applications that I
used to write somewhat painfully with
a bunch of regular expressions that
would definitely be much more simply
implemented now with a large language
model and a few prompts.
Yeah, I use ChatGPT to
proofread pretty much everything
I write these days, so I'm
excited to show you
some more examples in
the notebook now. So first we'll import
OpenAI and also use
the same get_completion helper function
that we've been using throughout
the videos. And the first thing
we'll do is a translation
task. So large language models are
trained on a lot
of text from kind of many sources, a
lot of which is
the internet, and this is kind of,
of course, in many different languages. So
this kind of imbues
the model with the
ability to do translation.
And these models know kind
of hundreds of languages to varying
degrees of proficiency.
And so we'll go through
some examples of
how to use this capability.
So let's
start off with something simple.
So in this first example,
the prompt is
translate the following
English text to Spanish. "Hi,
I would like to order a blender".
And the response is "Hola,
me gustaría ordenar una licuadora".
And I'm very sorry to all
of you Spanish speakers. I
never learned Spanish, unfortunately,
as
you can definitely tell.
Okay, let's try another example. So
in this example, the prompt is "Tell
me what language this is".
And then this is in French,
"Combien coûte le lampadaire".
And so let's run this.
And the model has identified that
"This is French."
The model can also
do multiple translations at once.
So in this example, let's
say translate the following text
to French and Spanish.
And you know what? Let's
add another an English pirate.
And the text is
"I want to order a basketball".
So here we have French,
Spanish and English pirate.
So in some languages,
the translation can change
depending on the speaker's
relationship to the listener. And
you can also explain this
to the language model. And
so it will be able
to kind of translate accordingly.
So in this example, we
say, "Translate
the following text to
Spanish in both the
formal and informal forms". "Would
you like to order a pillow?" And
also notice here we're using
a different delimiter than
these backticks. It doesn't
really matter
as long as there's kind of a
clear separation.
So here we have the formal and informal.
So formal is when you're
speaking to someone who's maybe
senior to you or you're in a
professional situation. That's when you
use a formal tone and then informal
is when you're speaking to maybe a
group of friends. I don't actually speak Spanish
but my dad does and he says
that this is correct. So
for the next example, we're
going to pretend that we're in
charge of a multinational e-commerce company
and so the user messages are going
to be in all
different languages and so
users are going to
be telling us about
their IT issues in a wide variety of
languages. So we need
a universal translator. So first we'll
just paste in a list of
user messages in a variety of different languages.
And now we will loop
through each of these user messages.
So "for issue in user_messages".
And then I'm going to copy over this
slightly longer code block.
And so the first thing we'll
do is ask the model
to tell us what language
the issue is in. So here's the
prompt. Then we'll print out
the original message's language and the
issue. And then we'll ask
the model to translate it into English and
Korean.
So let's run this.
So the original message in French.
So we have a
variety of languages and
then the model translates
them into English and then Korean.
And you can kind of see here,
so the model says, "This is French".
So that's
because the response from this
prompt is going to be "This
is French". You
could try editing this
prompt to say something
like tell me what
language this is, respond
with only one word or don't use
a sentence, that kind
of thing. If you
wanted this to just be one word. Or you
could ask for it in a JSON format
or something like that, which would
probably encourage it
to not use a whole sentence.
And so amazing, you've
just built a universal translator. And
also feel free to pause
the video and add kind
of any other languages you
want to try here. Maybe
languages you speak
yourself and see how the model
does.
So, the next thing we're
going to dive into
is tone transformation. Writing
can vary based on
an intended audience, you know, the
way that I would write an email to
a colleague or a
professor is obviously going
to be quite different
to the way I
text my younger brother. And so, ChatGPT
can actually also help
produce different tones.
So, let's look at some examples. So, in
this first example, the
prompt is "Translate
the following from slang
to a business letter". "Dude, this
is Joe, check out this spec on
the standing lamp."
So, let's execute this.
And as you can see, we have a much
more formal business letter
with a proposal for
a standing lamp specification.
The next thing that we're
going to do is to
convert between different formats. ChatGPT
is very good at translating between
different formats such
as JSON to HTML, you know, XML, all
kinds of things. Markdown.
And so, in the prompt, we'll
describe both the input
and the output formats. So, here
is an example. So, we
have this JSON that
contains a list of
restaurant employees with their
name and email.
And then in the prompt, we're
going to ask the
model to translate this
from JSON to HTML. So, the
prompt is "Translate
the following Python dictionary
from JSON to an
HTML table with column
headers and title".
And then we'll
get the response from the
model and print it.
So, here we have some
HTML displaying all of
the employee names and emails.
And so, now let's
see if we can actually view this HTML. So,
we're going to use this
display function from this Python library,
"display (HTML(response))".
And here you can see that this is
a properly formatted HTML table.
The next transformation task we're
going to do is spell
check and grammar checking. And
this is a really kind
of popular use for ChatGPT. I
highly recommend doing this, I
do this all the time. And it's especially
useful when you're working in
a non-native language. And so here are
some examples of some common grammar
and spelling problems and how the
language model can help address these.
So I'm going to paste in
a list of sentences that have some grammatical
or spelling errors.
And then we're going to loop through
each of these sentences
and ask the model
to proofread these.
Proofread and correct. And then we'll
use some delimiters.
And then we will get the
response and print it as usual.
And so the model is able to correct
all of these grammatical errors.
We could use some
of the techniques that we've
discussed before. So we could, to
improve the prompt, we
could say proofread and
correct the following text.
And rewrite.
And rewrite the whole.
And rewrite it.
Corrected version. If you don't
find any errors, just
say no errors found.
Let's try this.
So this way we were able to, oh,
they're still using quotes here. But
you can imagine you'd be
able to find a way
with a little bit of
iterative prompt development. To kind
of find a prompt that works more reliably
every single time.
And so now we'll do another example. It's
always useful to check your text
before you post it in
a public forum. And so we'll go through
an example of checking
a review. And so here
is a review about a
stuffed panda. And so we're
going to ask the model to proofread
and correct the review.
Great.
So we have this corrected version.
And one cool thing we can do is
find the kind of
differences between our original
review and the model's output. So
we're going to use this redlines Python
package to do this. And we're
going to get the diff between
the original text of
our review and the
model output and then
display this.
And so here you can see the diff
between the original review
and the model output
and the kind of
things that have been corrected. So,
the prompt that we used was,
"proofread and correct this review".
But you can also make
kind of more dramatic changes,
changes to tone,
and that kind of thing. So, let's
try one more thing. So, in
this prompt, we're going to ask the model
to proofread and correct
this same review, but also
make it more compelling and ensure
that it follows APA style and
targets an advanced
reader. And we're also going
to ask for the output
in markdown format. And so we're
using the same text from the original review
up here. So, let's execute this.
And here we have
an expanded APA style
review of the softpanda. So,
this is it for the transforming video.
Next up, we have "Expanding",
where we'll take a shorter prompt and
kind of generate a longer, more
freeform response from
a language model.